[Music]
harry and george are meant to be in sao
paulo receiving medical treatment for
their autism but instead they're sat in
heathrow's terminal too trying to get
there after delays forced them to miss
their connection their mother carla
feels stranded if i start to explain to
you hi i feel how you start crying
the situation from last night to today
this time it's been horrific that's the
only way i can explain to you i
experienced something that i wouldn't
believe i would ever experience with two
autistic kids special needs kids in an
airport that little boy was shaking
shaking and i said please can someone
help me
the airport has asked airlines operating
in two terminals to consolidate their
flights in other words cancel 10 of them
to lighten the load colton is one of
nearly 5 000 passengers now grounded
flew from johannesburg to london hoping
to get a connecting fight also in the
morning and when i arrived here we just
got a text saying the fight was canceled
pretty much i haven't seen my girlfriend
in 11 months and i'm proposing to her
tomorrow and i was supposed to see her
this morning so that really
really stinks disruption has lingered as
the industry struggles with the surge in
sun seekers post pandemic problems with
the baggage system at terminal 2 over
the weekend left hundreds waiting for
three hours to collect their luggage
issues with a lack of staff persist
fundamentally the issues that heathrow
are around it systems baggage systems
that can't cope coupled with fewer staff
that would normally be on duty due to
the staff shortage across the airports
and airlines and of course it's making a
misery for consumers who are hoping to
have a seamless trip and aren't getting
one
some airlines are trying to get ahead of
further last-minute chaos easyjet has
cut thousands of flights from gatwick
and amsterdam the effect already felt at
skipper airport where cues snake out of
the terminal building airlines reducing
the number of flights may be the most
sensible option in delivering a more
reliable service over the summer but it
still leaves millions of passengers
panicking about whether their flights or
holidays will be cancelled or delayed
carla harry and george are now booked on
a flight on wednesday but the delays
have already caused them to miss one
appointment in brazil
a reminder that for thousands of
families this isn't a missed commute or
holiday but a trip they're depending on
ashton harinag sky news